Donald Trump staffers have admitted to
planting what is effectively propaganda
news some call it fake news to counter
Trump's Twitter meltdown so the
backstory is that Donald Trump regularly
tweets absolutely insane stuff insults
threats unhinged political statements
conspiracy theories all that sort of
stuff to Twitter and we found out that
in the last few days of the presidential
campaign Trump basically had access to
Twitter completely cut off but we're now
learning about what was the more ongoing
strategy to prevent embarrassing Twitter
meltdowns during the campaign which
obviously didn't work six former
campaign officials have gone public as
how they tried to keep Trump tweeting
under control they would try to keep his
personal media consumption to mostly
praise when Trump would see a criticism
of himself that would often trigger the
worst of his tweeting so staffers would
try to only put in front of him positive
stories when they couldn't find positive
stories they would try to plant positive
stories by contacting right-wing media
and trying to get friendly stories
posted so then they could print those
out and give them to trump quote from a
former communications director named Sam
Nunn Berg if candidate Trump was upset
about unfair coverage it was productive
to show him that he was getting fair
coverage from outlets that were
persuadable staffers benefited from the
reality that Trump barely ever read
anything online they could actually
limit Trump news universe by printing
out only positive news which is
absolutely amazing and a lot of it was
mitigation which is they tried to line
things up in media to counter a
disastrous tweet so remember for example
when Trump went on Twitter and started
slamming Goldstar father kazeer Khan
whose army captain son died in combat
Trump started slamming because Eirik on
on Twitter the Trump staffers set up a
meeting for Trump with Gold Star Mothers
of Florida and then planted the story in
conservative media to try to push back
another example is when former Miss
Universe Aliya
Alicia Machado was calling out Trump for
referring to her as Miss Piggy and Miss
Housekeeping the communications team
ambled to put a story in FoxNews and the
Washington Examiner in Breitbart
that that was a positive story about
Trump's relationship to women or
whatever I actually think that the main
story which is a team had to try to
manage Trump's Twitter use that's not
the main story the revelation for me is
that there were individuals who admitted
that they were planting stories with
right-wing media which means they were
in direct contact during the campaign in
a way that that suggests that they were
heavily influencing coverage of Trump
which suggests to me Pat that they're
probably still in contact now within the
Trump White House and that while Trump
is calling any negative press fake news
the the practical reality is that a lot
of the Trump coverage you're seeing in
right-wing news has maybe been planted
there by Trump staffers themselves well
that's certainly the new revelation from
this but what's more fascinating to me
is that they have to have find this
roundabout solution yeah to limiting
Donald Trump's Twitter use you think
that you know this guy's on the
precipice being elected president United
States you can kind of just take that
away from him similar to President
Obama's staff taking away his blackberry
right he had been acting concerned was
any messaging with like Scarlett
Johansson and stuff like that and the
team said you can't do it anymore it's
not secure I don't remember the
specifics but I mean Donald Trump
promised he would stop using Twitter
once became president that's another
broken campaign for him yeah I haven't
happened if you're one of these staffers
why do you stay working for Trump right
I mean if your job is to micromanage him
through childish Tantrums on the
Internet how do you justify staying on
board I guess Hillary's emails or
something like that